[Music]
yes what happened to the bird where's
the bird crazy
[Music]
the bird was delicious oh he ate the
birds
[Music]
so let's get after it
it makes me hungry honestly
um
he got an interview it's a good one oh
my no way yes this is real he got an
interview no and it's a good one
Cuomo and welcome to another episode of
the Chris Cuomo project so the country's
talking about the president of Ukraine
Vladimir zielinski coming here even
though the war is going on comes to
America asking for support to deliver a
message of urgency we got to speak to
him right before
the Ukraine come see if Trump comes here
to America like that Mulan in that movie
from the 90s not coming to America
America what is the situation what are
his concerns not just for now but for
what he believes is coming in that
country and Beyond
bringing pistol my people
peace income president of Ukraine right
on the E of his big address to America
but they told me I could only air it two
weeks after it happened
and I put a [ __ ] suit on I hope that
prick put a suit on
[Music]
bro listen to the all the rock and roll
intro he's so cool he's so cool
Mr President thank you for joining us I
know the security situation is very
sensitive even centers there were again
it falls down like mayor Quimby and he
said the Bahamas massive bombing get
that steel drum out of the uh premier's
office
just around the time of this interview
what can you tell us by the way his
[ __ ] I'm Ukrainian we know you never
stop telling us
wait a minute he speaks English
he only begs in English
he won't do interviews in it
he knows English when you know you know
how a dog he speaks fine he speaks
English fine dude he understands English
fine
this is literally that frisky dingo bit
with Old Spice when there is you speak
English yes no but this is prop this is
meant to make people go like wow
it's meant to make him look look like
have mystique and they're all playing
along with it
yeah
how [ __ ] funny was it though all
right because because Chris Cuomo did
this interview like two weeks before he
gave his speech and [ __ ] or like right
before he gave the speech and then he
goes up there to do the speech and he
does it in English that's even worse
you're right because hello this [ __ ]
guy he spoke English
you [ __ ]
understand what he's saying Ma you
believe this I always think he's at his
mom he is he is he is he doesn't live
with his mom but he's like Tony he goes
over all the time he's checking on it
yeah that's for today
Russian aggression is still continues
wow this is terribly [ __ ] so he spoke
Ukrainian and then you poorly miked a
translator so that he's louder than the
translator this is really bad with our
Iranian drones an electrical grid of
ours look at the black face of Chris
Cuomo Ukraine's losing by the way you
saw the Washington Post report
that without our in without money from
the West they would be just dead
devastated they have nothing they're
losing they're winning they're losing
they've been losing they haven't stopped
losing as well as the Capital Kia and
the key of reaches I look I don't know a
lot about Ukraine or Russia but like
what's the difference between you two
people you know your food looks the same
by the way [ __ ] horrible
hey I'm not gonna lie you know it's like
uh I'm a Ukrainian broad I mean a
Russian broad what's the difference
about twenty dollars more for the
Ukrainian one they say they're clean I
don't know what that means
they're sex traffickers I don't know if
you know this they go straight from
container to table there's no middleman
yeah it's much more you're gonna get
that Organic Farm Fresh okay yes that's
right Miracle Cruisers are cheaper than
that I remember you just kind of
remember to wash the pesticides off yeah
you have to wash off you have to wash it
off and also Ukrainian hooker cheaper
than eggs now
locally sourced sex trafficking is the
best section it really is yeah as well
as the waters they put them in a lobster
tank like seafood it's a pick one yeah
but we're trying to deal with those
challenges you know every
the only thing every time every time
hell no I don't know that's right
uh every time
uh zielinski talks this is all I hear
nope that's it please give me more money
I need more money or a losing War
that's not fair Shane McMahon wore a
suit
and you know what like you know it's
like I've really taken out a lot of my
hate on zielinski and it's like I'm at a
point I don't even hate zielinski he's
our guy yes it's us we suck we're the
bad guys we're the idiots yeah
so she gave up translating
what is he saying does anybody speak
Ukrainian
are they gonna do this are they going to
do this like one of those cartoons or as
a joke like one guy understands them
like this is gonna be like an R2D2 thing
again where he's going to speak
Ukrainian and then Chris is going to go
you know you make some good points there
you know going back to what you were
saying about you know the Dom bass
region and yes this is a [ __ ] three
CP dope he can understand everything
he's saying see three feet dope yeah
um
look I want you to look at Chris Cuomo
because now they're not translating
anymore he has no idea what's going on I
want you while he's talking I know this
is more visual if you listen to audio
I'm sorry you just have to look at his
face look at him look at him
um
darkness my old friend
I didn't know anything you just [ __ ]
said I ain't gonna lie to you I got no
[ __ ] clue but you know I like your
hoodie I have one that says free agent
just like that one I almost would have
cut him off I feel like I'm being rude
if somebody's investing that much time
to speak to you the language and there's
no translator exactly no I'm not trying
to be rude but you wait you're wasting
sir yes sir you're wasting a lot of
Ukrainian on me right now
looks like he's thinking about sauce he
doesn't call us sauce he's from New York
he calls her gravy
foreign
what do you know about the number of
casualties and also do you know what to
do when a to take the the smell of a
dead bird out of a cold I'm asking
everybody
it sounds tragic I suffer some tragedy
too recently with this bird I don't want
to get into that right now
from today's bombing what happened to
the burgers where's the bird Chris
country is without power
he started talking oh because all of
this is the psy out but none of it's
real idiots because because they have as
long as you know you're as long as you
read your part of the script correctly
yeah it doesn't matter what he's saying
he's giving a recipe to a borsche for
all we know hey did you know Virgie when
they do voice acting sometimes the
actors aren't even in the same room yeah
that's true do you know the [ __ ]
zelinski has a Foley guy these two
probably aren't even talking to each
other there's like those little radio
things where they already have the
answers yes those oh that's right so
those Demi Lovato's here so your new
album's pretty you're pretty excited
tell me about that yeah thanks so much
it always sounds differently always
mixed higher it's always crazy
[Laughter]
the reason I'm saying for now
so either they don't translate or they
do translate but they speak exactly at
the same time so you don't know what
they're saying
I I Chris what's going on man they need
money I think is the point so we can
just get cut to the chase I can
translate we need money give me give me
money money money money
our National Emergency Services
this looks like somebody's stream
sniping a stream sniping stream
but did I'm no I'm sure they're not even
think that's funny anymore this feels
like
this was just recorded it does feel like
it was pre-recorded it just feels like a
prep Burger thing that we were talking
about radio I really I do believe that
yeah or it feels like I'm like if if I'm
you're doing day waiver I'm doing night
wave and you're and you just find like a
live speech or a speech that just came
out this feels like Chris is just
watching the speech like on a commentary
Channel
and then adding is commentary that's
that that's a really good point and uh
and then you decide here 35 bits guys
extremelabs.com Chris Cuomo project I
make him a twitch streamer I cannot
handle him playing Dead Boys donate you
can donate we got little pop-ups and
ends and everything's all badabing and
it's like a meatball yeah I'm gonna be
playing high on life uh this weekend if
you want to tune in we'll have some fun
uh premium chats uh 45 bits holy [ __ ]
did you see that headshot that Foggers
in the chat bogus
I also got a new uh new coin coming out
the Como coin uh he's gonna start
shielding his own [ __ ] crypto coin no
yeah Como coin
it's an nft
stays for nice [ __ ] tits
like to also announced my sponsorship
with G fuel marinara flavor
we're going to translate it later for
you buddy
so what do I do I just look at them
just sit there Chris
I heard you say this summer uh that
you're very grateful for the help but
that you can't fly with just one wing
and that One Wing is nice but you can't
fly with just one Wing you need to touch
like a bird everything that will help
you why are we throwing so much money at
them when we didn't have three billion
for the wall
I'm sorry but some borders are more
important than other borders
it's just so angry it's not like the
Sinaloa cartel is ripping a car part of
country at our border right now
or not to send a low excuse me the
cartels that are replacing the Sinaloa
because the Sinaloa believe it or not
and this is true you look it up we're
actually the good ones not that they
were good they're terrible you don't
even get like the Jalisco cartel there's
your issue guys and those guys are way
crazy these Sinaloa Sinaloa were the
ones that said never [ __ ] with tourists
you never [ __ ] with resort areas you
never [ __ ] with the money because like
we want these people to like us that way
they let us sell drugs and then we can
pay off people and we're fine but now
the problem is now that they got rid of
the both chapos is him and his son they
captured his son now what you got is a
bunch of cartels that go into and
literally murder people they don't give
a [ __ ] who you are it's way worse now it
is way worse Just One Wing
when is
difficult for me to answer this question
um as you know it's much like our
passengers
and the Very name of the aircraft
we're flying and we're buddies
I was watching the show Lost we just got
it here so I'm doing a lot of plane
metaphors now
yeah I never watch or don't spoil it all
right I got to the part with a smoke
monster I had them very confused it's
lots of symbols around the island I
don't know much why is the fat we're not
losing weight he's been on the island
for seven years oh remember that was how
many people would point that out on that
show it's like yo Hurley's still like
400 pounds bro why isn't he losing
weight like you would be [ __ ]
shredded after a year on an island like
that
yeah in English especially with the diet
you'd be eating it would all be like
fresh fruits and like fresh [ __ ]
vegetables and [ __ ] it would be like all
and if you got me to be like fresh bored
that's what I mean yeah
you'd have to kill and skin it before
you could eat it so by the time you get
to eat literally no sugar accepting
coconut that's a good point yeah coconut
water fresh for me coconut there are not
enough against Russia
yeah but one of your wings costs us 140
billion dollars and the reason that
we're pissed is because you don't even
appreciate it you just come here and say
it's not enough please giving us more
because the only thing keeping together
their economy is our money
this is true
yeah
sometimes in a difficult situation
okay there's too many play metaphors and
I'm kind of done here
um yeah he just wants more money